thank you
have you ever heard of a service called
protonmail it's been out for nearly 10
years now and and extremely popular
amongst enthusiasts in fact they have
over 70 million users but the average
person hasn't never even heard of this
service this is quite a shame because
protonmail was essentially designed to
be a better version of Gmail from every
aspect for example protonmail doesn't
even know who you are they don't even
ask for a name to open a protonmail
email address conversely Gmail asks for
a full name date of birth gender and
phone number the only information that
you have to give protonmail is another
email address or phone number just so
that they can verify that you're
actually a human and that you're not
just trying to open a crap ton of
accounts but even this data is only
briefly stored and is promptly deleted
after vacation is completed the Privacy
doesn't just stop at sign up either
protona also doesn't track your IP
address or review any of the emails that
you send or receive additionally all of
the emails that you send and receive are
completely end to end encrypted which is
not the case with the Gmail Gmail does
encrypt your emails when possible but
their encryption is inherently inferior
because they rely on something called
TLS encryption the problem is that TLS
encryption not only works when both
descending and receiving server support
the standard we should also note that
Google holds all of the keys to set
encryption so while tlis encryption may
protect you against hackers it doesn't
actually protect your privacy against
Google protonmail on the other hand uses
something called pgp encryption which is
not server dependent the only person who
has the keys to open your email is the
actual recipients of your email so
object actively speaking protonmail
blows Gmail out of the water in terms of
privacy and security yet Gmail still
destroys a protonmail when it comes to
market share so why doesn't no one want
protonmail despite it offering
everything that people supposedly want
foreign
taking a look back one of the main
factors that has held back protonmail
over the years is that they don't have a
very strong background virtually every
popular email client that has ever
existed has been backed by a mega tech
company whose main business was not
email for example AOL was AOL Yahoo was
Yahoo Hotmail was Microsoft and Gmail
was of course Google this is no
coincidence the reality is that creating
an email service is not only expensive
but it's not exactly lucrative either I
mean have you ever wondered how Gmail
even makes money in the first place
historically email providers made money
by showing you ads throughout the UI but
that's not really a thing in 2023 the
way that email providers make money
today is by sending you personalized ads
to your inbox you know that promotions
tab under your Gmail account that's why
that's there but virtually no one ever
opens up that tab or clicks on those
emails so most email users don't make
their provider any money directly but
companies like Google and Microsoft are
more than okay with that your goal with
Gmail and Outlook aren't to make money
their goal is to Simply control market
share and create Synergy between all of
their services this makes their data
collection and app targeting way easier
when you log into your Google account on
a new computer they already know exactly
who you are so the next time you search
on Google they don't have to waste time
serving you low quality generic ads
instead they can serve your targeted ads
that have a far greater likelihood of
converting as you can see email services
are much more of a customer acquisition
Avenue as opposed to a real money driver
and this makes it extraordinarily
difficult for a company to be built
around it just doing emails which a
protonmail has figured out firsthand
these struggles date back to the launch
of protonmail itself within just three
days of beta launch protonmail was
running into server capacity issues this
forced them to temporarily suspend new
signups until they could expand server
capacity while understandable this isn't
exactly a great first impression to make
things worse they had to resort to
crowdfunding to actually continue
growing fortunately their supporters
were extremely generous and helped them
destroy their fundraising goal but
PayPal had other plans PayPal would end
up freezing a quarter million dollars
worth of donations because they
apparently had concerns regarding the
legality of encryption proton would
eventually work through all of these
obstacles but these are simply examples
of pain points that their competitors
never even had to deal with well
actually technically Google did have
server capacity issues because they were
trying to offer 200 times more storage
than everyone else but they actually
managed to turn that into an vintage
they maintained a Gmail as an
invite-only platform for many years
which created an Allure of exclusivity
for proton however these obstacles were
truly just obstacles
foreign
facing infrastructure challenges that
made it difficult to grow protona also
had to address the elephant in the room
which was how they were actually going
to make money given that they weren't
collecting any user data they couldn't
create or deliver any targeted ads they
could deliver generic ads but that would
kind of go against their whole brand
image so that was off limits as well
this meant that the only way that proton
could reliably make money was from their
consumers themselves which is not
exactly a bad thing the reason that
consumers have to pay proton is because
with Pro Donna there were actually the
customers with every other email service
the advertisers or the customers and the
users are actually the products with
that being said though people have
become accustomed to getting email for
free so proton has to work through a
pretty large mental barrier we should
note that protons does have a free tier
but it's not sufficient for any sort of
personal application the free tier only
comes with 500 megabytes of storage and
if you're regularly emailing documents
presentations and spreadsheets you'll
probably run out of storage by the time
you even get to 100 emails you can boost
this to one gigabyte by completing a few
additional steps but that doesn't really
make the situation at all that much
better and I don't think any of us want
to go back to the days of constantly
deleting old emails so realistically you
would want to spring for at least the
protonmail plus plan which comes in at 5
Euros per month or 48 Euros per year on
the theme of protecting your privacy we
should note that proton accepts
cryptocurrency payments so you don't
have to give them your credit card
details or anything like that anyway if
you do spring for this plan you'll
actually get a service that's comparable
to gmail you get an account that can
support up to 10 email addresses 15
gigabytes of storage custom domains and
auto reply features you also get access
to the proton driver proton calendar and
even the proton VPN if you take it one
step further and spring for the proton
Unlimited Plan you'll have to pay 12
euros per month or 120 euros per year
but this will boost your email address
limit to 15. your storage limit to 500
gigabytes and your custom domain limit
to three so proton is absolutely a
viable email service but to unlock this
functionality you have to pay and though
people say that they value their privacy
and security over everything else the
reality is that most people don't
evaluate those enough to pay for it
especially because they've gotten used
to not pay for it we should also note
that paying 50 or 120 euros per year for
an email account is only viable in the
western world and by the looks of it
proton has already won over much of this
market so until proton is able to afford
to give out more generous free tiers I
suspect that they'll continue to
struggle when it comes to breaking in to
the mainstream market
even if we put aside proton shortfalls
in terms of infrastructure and revenue
they still have to overcome likely the
biggest obstacle which is the Obstacle
of convenience and I'm not talking about
the convenience of protonmail itself
they have a beautiful modern bubbly UI
that's on par with if not better than
the competition so it's not the
convenience of the UI that will hold
them back rather it's the convenience of
the email address itself while people
don't like big companies collecting
personal data to make money this data
collection is what allows for many of
the conveniences that we've become
accustomed to take login with Google for
example the only reason that this
service works is because Google is able
to pass on all of the data that the
service needs from your Google account
but proton wouldn't even be able to
autofill your name much less your phone
number address or payment information
proton is trying to address the
shortfall with the recent acquisition of
simple a login but it's not clear how
useful the service will be given
proton's overall goals of privacy it's
not just new account creation that will
become more difficult either it'll
become substantially harder to sync
changes between devices for example
let's say you told Chrome on your
computer to save your password for
Amazon with a Google account the Chrome
on your iPhone and an iPad would
automatically know this password and the
next time you try to access Amazon on
your iPhone or iPad it'll auto fill
surely giving that up is just a minor
inconvenience but this could have become
a lot more annoying when you get a new
computer or laptop altogether imagine
how many Chrome extensions that you
would have to reinstall how many
passwords you would have to re-enter and
how many files you would have to
transfer ironically these were all
Givens when buying a new device 10 to 15
years ago but thanks to the cloud
cookies and yes data collection these
have all become struggles of the past
for most of us by switching to proton
now however however you would lose many
of the perks that come along with having
a Gmail Google account but at least
those are just inconveniences as opposed
to full-on obstacles the reality is that
protonmail also comes along with a game
breaking obstacle here's the thing what
type of person would be looking for a
completely Anonymous email address
people looking for privacy yes but also
Shady people hackers spammers Etc so
naturally many companies and governments
are wary of proton email addresses and
many of them have actually full-on
blocked proton email addresses
altogether so you'll also need to have a
backup email address from one of the big
providers to actually use services from
these companies which kind of defeats
the whole purpose of proton in the first
place you can get around this by using a
custom domain but that gets into the
whole paid service problem all over
again
in the end proton male is the perfect
example of our love-hate relationship
with big Tech you would think that the
internet would be jumping up and down at
the side of this product but protonmail
has already been out for nearly 10 years
and they're still only appealing to a
niche demographic the reality is that
while people hate that their data is
being collected they've also gotten used
to all of the conveniences that come
along with that what proton is trying to
accomplish is truly commendable but
while they've been able to achieve a
significant amount of success within a
niche market the mainstream prospects
are not nearly as clear it appears that
the hurdles of getting people to pay for
an email service along with the
shortfalls in terms of convenience or
simply too much to overcome but I'd be
happy to be proven wrong would you be
willing to switch to protonmail comment
that down below also drop a like if you
have a love-hate relationship with the
big Tech as well and of course consider
checking out Discord Community suggested
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions honestly answered but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign